j'en parlais au début de l'émission
aujourd'hui c'est la fête de la musique
et nous allons donc par les chansons et
morceaux avec le rappeur asco bonjour à
vous vous êtes accompagné de votre
manager fresnel et de mehdi qui figure
qui joue dans votre dernier clip c'est
pour ça qu'on vous invitez puisque l'un
des clips de votre deuxième album vient
tout juste de sortir
alors avant d'en parler bas je vous
propose de regarder un petit extrait
où sont les hommes qui sont derrière les
femmes à guetter leurs formes l'amour ça
rend à greg mais les hommes sont des
bornes bourg et d'alcool et d'arrogance
drôle de soirée et coureur de jupons qui
veulent des femmes voilées
ils sont contradictoires et ne savent
pas ce qu'ils veulent ils préfèrent est
très mal accompagnée que de rester seule
mais qu'il prend pour singe il toujours
là plus que c'est qu'un chef vacances
peut-être pour ça qu'il appelle moi bus
sa femme at elle raison l'homme y est il
sur 1,6 et qui se ressemble s'assemble
ils finiront avec la nuit roy et joly
bachelor at offrir des roses me
demanderont jamais tamil de membres aux
deux jours autre chose
cette nouvelle chanson qui est non le
clip et est sorti le 14 juin s'intitule
où sont les hommes
j'ai l'impression dans ce morceau nous
les hommes justement on en prend pour
notre grade non parce qu on va dire
c'est plus une remise en question
j'avais fait un morceau qui s'applique
sur les formes où j'avais critiqué la
junte féminine pas dans sa généralité
j'avais sublime catégorie on a souvent
reproché en tant qu'homme je pensais
qu'on a je pense encore qu'on a notre
part de responsabilité dans le problème
entre les hommes et les femmes que j'ai
décidé d'en parler c'est une réaction
d'orgueil justement par rapport à ces
reproches que vous aviez déjà se
projette sur ce morceau en fait qu'il
c'est super dur de se remettre en
question donc on va dire c'est une
autocritique
d'abord parce que je me sens ciblés dans
certaines de mes phrases et ensuite un
bon point de vue vis-à-vis de certaines
catégories d'hommes
voilà ce morceau fait partie donc de
votre deuxième album qui devrait sortir
à l'automne à peu près le thème général
de cet album c'est aussi ses relations
hommes femmes où il y aura des morceaux
un petit peu plus différent il y aura
des morceaux différents même si c'est
vrai que jusqu'à aujourd'hui les
morceaux qu'on a mis en avant c'est un
peu les morceaux hommes femmes
célibataires ou sur les femmes ou les
hommes c'est un peu
voilà il y aura d'autres notes d'hôtel
de tout ça reste grand public de toute
façon quoi qu'il arrive autres on va
dire lixhausen album oui et non oui oui
dans le sens où la plupart des morceaux
seront publiques non parce qu'il faut
que mais aussi des morceaux un peu plus
dure un peu plus contestataire
aujourd'hui je le disais fresnel c'est
la fête de la musique
la ministre de la culture aurélie
filippetti ce matin en parler d'une
crise du marché du disque
est-ce que c'est plus dur avec
l'explosion d'internet de nombreux
artistes sur internet voilà de faire
émerger des artistes comme comme asco
moi je pense que c'était pas que il ya
des avantages et des inconvénients
certes on peut pas nier a vraiment une
crise du disque on le voit très bien
virgin enfermé plusieurs magasins décédé
ce
les cd physiques sont beaucoup moins
mais à d'autres formes de de voir que la
visibilité qui se met en place par
exemple maintenant les gens et on vend
ce qu'on appelle décès au format
numérique en fait on vend des cd virtuel
et internet aussi a permis à pas mal
d'artistes de devoir du jour c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne pour asco notamment
sur ses ventes
un petit peu sur son premier album par
exemple à ce son premier album on était
encore
dans un support physique on a vendu en
arrondi de céder on arrondit décédé
physiquement mais aujourd'hui le
prochain qui va arriver ça être
numérique le cd pour passer au séminaire
et que votre masse énergie numérique
j'ai vu d'ailleurs que sur votre chaîne
vidéo sur un site de player vous avez
7000 vu déjà sur sur ce clip là c'est sa
part plutôt pas mal non cimpan
américaines du jour on va dire ça part
plutôt pas mal même si mes espérances et
nos espérances étaient un peu moins bien
on a peut-être été un peu gourmand gens
souhaitaient plus mais je fais pas voir
c'est un bon début pourvu que ça dure
c'est sur la longue qu'il faut que ça
dure dans ce clip mehdi vous vous y
participez vous êtes aussi connu
dorénavant pour avoir gagné l'émission
la belle et ses princes c'est votre
première apparition dans un clip où vous
avez déjà fait non justement ce qu'une
première expérience et donc je remercie
à ce qu à cette époque là ce que c'est
quand même à quelques années maintenant
moi je voulais voir comment ça se
passait au niveau d'être derrière la
caméra est donc là c'était un petit peu
de l'acteur innoncence ou voilà j'avais
un rôle à jouer
je pense je le joue assez assez bien
c'est marrant de se voir et en plus
justement oui ça tombe avec la belle et
ses princes très peu ce rôle de goujat
avec les femmes sa fin c'est drôle parce
que je sais que je pense que c'est une
étiquette mais qui n'est vraiment pas
fondées dans le sens où je suis à
l'opposé de ça dans la vie de tous les
jours donc c'est drôle moi je le vois
d'un autre notre manière que les autres
courts je peux pas m'empêcher de vous
poser la question du non après après
l'émission
pourquoi avoir quitté nelly qu'est ce
qui s'est passé bon c'est tout cela me
plaisait pas physiquement mentalement
non mais c'est ça me plaisait pas et en
plus de ça dès le départ je n'ai pas été
dans cette émission là pour trouver
l'amour je le joue je voudrais trouver
l'amour je n'irai pas la télé pour le
faire et en l'occurrence mandat là
c'était pour lui si tu y participer pour
la compétition voir jusqu'où jusqu'où je
peux aller face aux autres beaux gosses
est moins beau gosse en maintenant j'ai
gagné donc j'étais plutôt satisfait de
moi même mais j'ai été clair dès le
départ avec et enfin le prétexte des
départs en australie c'était aussi
sévère
au départ je suis partie 2 octobre je
suis rentré en france en janvier
je regarde mon passeport pour vous
montrer pour le tampon c'est ça revenons
à ce nouveau morceau là le l'album est
en préparation
il ya encore des morceaux à écrire à
produire où vous en êtes à ce qu on va
dire j'ai fait des trois quarts je suis
aussi satisfait du travail que j'ai fait
jusqu'à là il me reste quelques morceaux
en finisse avec le freiner l'équipe au
complet ou dauphins dit et toute
l'équipe de l'ice prod on va essayer
d'affiner sa et enfin essayer de faire
un bon produit un bon projet pour pas
avoir de regret je sais que auparavant
vous allez me un petit peu encontre
parenthèse justement votre carrière de
rappeur là vous investissez à nouveau au
maximum dans cet album mais le truc
c'est de pas avoir de regret donc à mon
avis faut s'investir au maximum
donc là on s'investit en maximum ou
n'exploite vraiment le shaq qui pourra
mettre en avant on va le mettre vraiment
en avant donc là je vois qu'il ya un
clip
c'est un ancien on abat ses droits
devant bas qualité ou à exploiter
jusqu'au bout il a été plus d'un mois
numéro 1 sur trace tv dans le domaine it
voilà c'est ce genre d'ouverture qui ont
essayé d'exploiter au maximum
preuve que ça peut fonctionner donc le
rap alors actuelle merci à tous les
trois d'être venu dans cette suite
week-end et puis rendez vous à la
rentrée pour la sortie du nouvel album
merci beaucoup plus